oh hey hey hey buddy so much fun there
haha I'm here hello who's that over
there is that to the right that's me
that's me that's me I'm gonna give you a
KC nice that wave that's how he waves a
FIFO hello all right so what do we do
what are we doing here so first we have
to press this red button and then okay
it starts the map so now we have to open
this box get it grenade out and throw it
at each other all right easy no where
you going where why dad that way no
shouting about your own failures is
maybe entertaining for some people but
for professional gamers like me we don't
care what are you talking about that's
all you've done for six years
shot about my successes and my successes
are that I'm gonna blow your ass away I
having never played this game before I
feel like I'm at a distinct disadvantage
don't worry
oh you can left-click there goes my
frames again it's two frames oh it's bad
why are you frames ah I've turned to
jello hang on wait you actually through
two rooms different two frames I like my
stats are pretty bad by like marks a
zero wins zero kills two deaths oh
please you have 18 deaths you can't
exactly say that proportionality at all
of you what you hate all what did I do
to you I'm just trying to play a nice
friendly game of grenade all of you yeah
I am about I'm about to blast your ass
from
debug to frames frames frames frames
frames friends is just gone there we go
I'm back now apparently I don't know why
that happens where is your left arm
don't worry about it's right in front of
me I don't you don't need to worry about
where my arm is worry about where your
arm is I'm dead yeah I know
see maybe you should should have worried
about where your arm was i stupid can I
not pull the pin once I pick this up I
don't understand
yeah put your finger in the pin now
frames frames frames frames okay we're
back wait no it's fine
frames the frames by frame rate wipe
frame rate my frame rate go bad are you
telling me they didn't optimize this
game to be high quality look like the
kind of game that they would optimize
yes I played this game before it was
perfectly fine so only when I join you
as for me it's not fine for me hang on
I'm gonna I'm gonna restart the game I'm
getting out here screw you guys screech
and every one of you guys all of you at
the same time screw you how do we
restart the how do we play I do it okay
oh wait does it oh okay well I hosted
the server
oh wait does it okay no your frames
they're better now I've restarted the
game and it's definitely better oh you
know what it yell frames frames pretend
more wrong with me I'm telling you guys
have a problem and you got you guys
should be late we're gonna hear about my
issues so I don't care about you I don't
care about your issues I don't care
about yours oh you should know I
shouldn't you having issues is better
for me no it's not I'm putting it
obviously not I had a ton of issues and
you still died so whose fault is this
did we start I'm pushing my button
alright get ready cuz you guys are dunzo
by the way I know you guys were
concerned but the frames are bad bad
frames
frames why what this is not fair very
clearly not fair why are you guys
brewing my frames Bob and I decided to
get together earlier and take away your
frames I can't I can't I can't I can't I
can't I can't
maybe it's a multistream maybe somebody
maybe maybe watching the multi stream is
causing the soprano turn off the multi
stream won't go back into the game it's
still crap Bob see Bob's needed by the
way I'll bet Bob if you know that hello
hello Bob
I I need I need to I'll be right back
hang on I'm turning the graphics quality
to very low do you about the guy who had
bad frame issues okay have you got a
good frames right now but I have a funny
feeling that's gonna stop well fine I'm
sure we'll hear about it whatever man I
feel like actually I should be able to
share with my friends the problems that
I'm having and you guys are just like
right when I go for trying to put the
pin in it framedrops everything's fine
until I'm trying to pull them I pulled
the pin hang on wait I got thought hey
throw it throw it let go let go I didn't
even show the game I didn't even show
the game to people I didn't even show
you
I'm such a bad let's Blaire I'm so bad
I'm just the worst I can't do anything
right I can't why don't I get any fur
I'm looking it up hang on I'm looking it
up goodbye game I'm looking it up help
please somebody help okay there's two
fixes I'm gonna do this real quick and
then we're gonna play a real good game
here we're gonna play a good game and
I'm gonna beat you guys right
Bob you needed to get out of you meant
to be no I don't know what you're so
worked up about mark
I'm just funny man I'm laughing man I'm
laughing I'm just over here trying to
jam it in the hole and wait skill
himself for me I appreciate that I'm a
master of I can't even get okay all
right okay all right
okay our master of the fruits okay all
right you know what know what I don't
know man wait wait we've got to fix I
start a new one cut him off start a new
one no once Bob gets in here got another
idea
okay now restart it apparently that fix
on okay and now apparently this should
be all good so I should be good to go
here all right so far I'm sailing smooth
sailing so far oh yeah this is smooth as
butter this is smooth
goddamn it there goes my frames Oh
goodbye guys at some point we used to be
friends who cared about each other and
who's aboard at each other when we were
low and had problems and now I feel like
you're just smacking me while I'm down
Oh bro
why don't bro me what bro what dude no
I'm watching you my friends are good now
I don't know why now that I'm not play
yeah wait for me your left hand was just
your the whole left arm is gone I feel
like my pins not my pin doesn't want to
do the thing I found like just shaking
the grenade around the pin jizz man oh
damn it
yeah that was my secret I was gonna tell
you guys I just grabbed the grenade
shake it like crazy till the pin falls
out that I just launched it like that oh
[ __ ] yeah pretty good there pretty good
pretty good
ready dead Bob you don't need to blow my
ass up I read online that blowing up
mark once is dead will fix his frames no
I've got even worse frames it's just
really not a good game to play for the
first time on stream okay got it into a
into a throwing position hmm and then
violently shake it and then oh wow where
to go where to go well it you guys are
gonna go down my frames are good we're
gonna go down just like your frames no I
think it's you shaking your grenade I
think that's what doing it cuz I kept
getting little frames every time someone
was shaking your grenade you got little
friends before I even got a grenade no
no are you shaking your did you grab a
grenade no I don't have a grenade yet
see that's the problem you can't grab a
grenade my friends my frames all the
pins out I can't make my grenades throw
to save my damn life I can't make frames
to save my damn life maybe it's just the
grin it no it was the surgery one two I
don't know what's going on I have
perfectly right now everyone wave their
arms as hard as you can
[Music]
I've got a frame great friends great
frames update great friends all day
great friends baby great friends great
frames great friends okay that's good
grape frames every time you grab a
grenade it's you every time you grab the
grenade every time oh I hope you die
frames I can't make it free
oh no one cares everyone cares I can't
why is my button why is my lid up what
well it's already open whoa whoa barks
[ __ ] you're cheating hang on yeah my lid
is very oh no I don't know you frantic
okay I just gotta get the shooting I
just gotta get a grenade out before the
frames get back go on I can't oh the one
time my lid is open I can't grab a
[ __ ] grenade before you [ __ ] god
[Music]
[ __ ] doll oh my god where's it going
not far enough
oh I'm gonna lose my mind I'm gonna lose
my [ __ ] mind
where is handsome Euler headquarters cuz
I want to have a word with the
developers of this game because I need
to have a conversation with them what we
should try a different map okay no all
right fine let's do yes I agree I got it
we're gonna fishing let's go fishing
let's go fishing
that's nice um fishing that sounds
peaceful oh sweet Jesus Oh what is this
God jeez [ __ ] what is this oh yeah see
you Bob I can't ever grab my Pole I'm
here he's behind you he's behind you oh
I'm gonna restart fix it for mark oh
right right right that'll fix it that'll
fix it
it's just
relaxing fishing adventure oh [ __ ] you
have to bait the hook you sure do
Oh No Oh what if I can't grab my pole it
just rolled off my lap what I can't
reach my pole it rolled off my lap just
keep working at it man you guys didn't
know I can't reach it it's it's it's not
reachable come on you're gonna reach it
hang on wait oh here we go here we go no
wait this doesn't make any sense
guys you don't understand it's not
grabbing it oh yeah wait no no don't go
oh yeah me I'm going I'm clipping right
through them it just went farther is it
went far though how did know you'll get
it keep trying it keep trying trying
it's not going there's no way I can't
it's not physically grabbing it it's too
far oh god oh god
okay guys every star lost football you
lost your bowl oh we have to restart it
because you lose your bull yeah it's the
boat ate my pole I didn't just drop it
the boat I think I'm a fairness mark I
think we should restart I didn't drop my
port thank you you know what I'm gonna
assume you did this for me cuz my pole
was clear got it okay I've got it
my pulls to the don't lose the pole but
I would never
wait what's happened some serious
trouble with that last time no no no I
don't lose poles yeah if we lose our
poles which prior restart no no no no
cuz of what I had to endure if you lose
a pole it's your own damn fault that
you're dumb maybe if you want to make
the rules you should have posted I
would've I probably would have good
friends with your frames I don't want it
I don't want to risk Bob and I have it's
bad quality that's true that's true just
trying to think of the greater good here
why did we agree to do this but this
whole thing this whole day this whole
streaming thing why'd we agree
everything was perfectly fine in my
lifetime my frames are good why am i
dabbing
why does the hand drink it should be
staying still right that's a logical
thing why does only two of the thingies
work
goddamn [ __ ] thing whatever this is
so would you really gonna make fun of me
don't make fun of me oh no oh no no it's
on the precipice of I don't know how you
be how do you be oh I dropped a larvae
how do you master this trouble my camera
just locked into place I can't move my
head anymore oh wait why is my arm
drifting around oh we have a random we
have a random oh [ __ ] all out
oh my [ __ ] progress I made no now
it's up I'm in I'm in it surgery you
[ __ ] what you didn't change yours what
what you all have to change on your
engine
alright [ __ ] damn it don't you blame
me for you guys frames I my frames are
fine now they got all better
they went to frame hospital they got
some free medicine drugs
Oh drugs framed rusty who is that I see
mark to my left worse wait wait wait for
my frames restart the game fishing pole
I lost my fishing pole restart the game
okay oh wait I've got an idea
no what the hell no no no no wait my
frames are still bad can you give it a
good old research oh nothing frames I
think wait come on you want everyone to
have a good experience please give it a
really good
loser all right last one though okay
good
it was my frames my friends were so bad
I just couldn't couldn't do that
give me your worms that sounds weird
what doesn't give me your worms that's
perfectly normal
I can't I can't I can't you can't I
can't I can't no I can't but you can't
do it guys you know what do you know
that mockery never you said to make
progress I can see you something
progress I'm restarting oh whatever yeah
I'm never gonna make progress
joke's on you stupid idiot what are you
thinking it's like he's bait they just
don't grab there's no grabbing them is
it physically possible to grab these
[ __ ] things I don't understand why is
the hook stuck on my or why is the hook
stuck of my or well no I don't care why
I don't care why frankly I don't wear oh
[Applause]
good god how is this game like hax cuz
how'd they get in there probably I don't
know alright well I was cool because I
play a different game
no I want to catch a fish I'm gonna
catch a fish and we're gonna I have
that's a game I have good frames alright
it just cuz every time I grab for a bait
my frame drops but I can if I get it and
I cast it
I'll be good let's just try it again
Marty I'm out says my chat I showed the
name I didn't show the name I did show
that was me that was me I showed the
name completely that was me that was all
on me and I take full responsibility for
that but listen when I showed that name
I did it in full confidence that I could
trust my fan base turns out my fan base
is full of a bunch of douche bags
alright so let's try not showing the
secret game wait is there a new name yes
would you like me to say it out loud for
you yes no wait I think we need to
restart for marks frames mark's fishing
pole is coming through the boat maybe
yours is
I guess you want to restart for the
Froyo yeah for his frames restart for
his frames
restart from that didn't count as me
calling for a restart for my frames I
was like mark can't call front of the
restart no no no no no no no Bob called
the restart in and his frames very bad I
know I wasn't gonna restart for Bob yet
but you said I needed to restart no no
no no no I didn't I I didn't say that
you you you're liar by the liars the
host because I think mark are to use the
purity to restart for my fragrance
that's his friends that's his prey now
both restarts are done he called for his
frames and he called for my friends I
can still call for your frames Bob
streams and my own frame still I need to
restart for my frames god dammit
seriously though is there some kind of
trick to like grabbing a bait
cuz I'm literally just tossing him
around I cannot figure it out for the
life of me me either
half my fingers don't work oh well I got
locked in head mode again I don't know
how happen shift gets you out of it no
I'm viewing with no I do and make the
middle mouse button it goes to head move
no I know I didn't do it it was I was
grabbing a bait and suddenly I'm in head
mode and if I click middle mouse button
I need it
god no restart for frames mark and ask
for it oh no you don't get the fishing
pole you're [ __ ] your bones that's
what I keep saying oh [ __ ] please don't
talk to me like that
Oh Oh daddy Papa I have got some brain
restart still warframe restarts okay
okay I got it I got my pole I managed to
recover my pole
where's my hour going through my body I
feel better about what's happening in my
life yeah I'm pretty good I'm
yes no no restarting four frames don't
frame to find franpsycho restart for
free frames are fine block Rams are fine
I've never had better frames I've never
had better frames frames are the best
they've ever been I swear dreams every
time I get into a position where I could
grab it it's dead flies away your bait
is gone no it's not it's there
don't what weird mic where'd I go
where'd I go where'd I go where'd I go
I have no frames frames are bad where's
my weird did it go everything's gone
buddy
what do you mean I go
[Applause]
first of all you already lost your bait
it was not on your hook no it was fine
don't trust your screen of what my
situation is for frame I was fine I was
so happy
whoa what the [ __ ] I got that thing to
happen to mark where my head got locked
yeah it happened to me too I think I
think Wade's cheated yeah I can't do
anything either
yeah all right it's okay I'll restart
for phrase just it's when people grab
too aggressively in the bait jar for
some reason for some reason you got a
bait real tenderly like I've got it it's
it's in the your bait fell off no it did
not
no it didn't I I saw I saw it's still
there it's still there I just I just
can't see the bait on my end then cuz
you have a naked hook on my end I've got
it it's good it's fine don't restart
oh I'm not I've got a bait on a hook I
hate all of you we're just gonna calm
the [ __ ] down everybody I'm okay I'm
calm I'm [ __ ] calm I'm calm be [ __ ]
call I'm calm yes you're come come come
come
I'm calm wait what you do in your
bedroom is really none of our business
okay calm down
yeah [ __ ] Oh point it off it oh yeah
swallow it whole frames frames the
bobber I think goes completely under
mine's bouncing right now mush bouncing
My Mind's bouncing mines bouncing oh I
think I feel better about my position in
all of that and it's like it's fine it's
listen Bob you were doing real good but
restart for free I forgot if you explode
your bait it just locks you in this
position of being in lucky mode how are
you locked again yep
I am so long bucket all right fine
frame is that a yes I good job way good
call good call when you need when you
need frames you frame it up I never said
the word frame oh wait frames Frank
please please calm down
praise well okay that's the last frames
oh I hate you
frames no everyone shut up I don't like
this frames no no no don't you [ __ ]
dare I will no it's fine
everything's fine is that friends no no
frame call
who's calling four frames who's doing it
nobody o frames
[Applause]
no you have to hate me watch you Axel's
much my final frames no frames no frames
ray
no don't frames two people yelling frame
no no I I was yelling beams I was
yelling splaine's I broken so no one
cares it's your own fault for host so I
can't I've become one with this bait it
has entered my head and it's falling out
that frames no no I will destroy your
entire family goochie goochie goo mr.
pol him who wants a delicious maggot no
right no don't do it
I've got got enough frames yet no you
guys made me watch for like five minutes
it's been five minutes yeah well not
yeah well shut up frames
no no no it's pure wedding it's pure
wedding the beta Spiro adding the phrase
no it's not a frames it's going in
glorious 60fps is no frames it's hot
know it okay I have plenty of frames I
need friends no Bob it's true both
frames
[Music]
no no no no no stay over here
you've become an old southern man in
here come on fight
come on yellow worm [ __ ] just please
no come on no not like this baby listen
she didn't mean anything it's always
better please I don't want a divorce
No what about the children come on we
can work it out Oh your therapist it's
fine it's fine
I have bait on rod I have achieved rod
baby voices in your head everything's
fine what okay it's in the water it's in
the water I hate this hey how are you
guys doing I almost shoot I need other
concentration I don't care about your
divorce proceedings frames no oh no
frames no one said anything about frames
please just let me have this one I got
it I caught a fish kiss me I'll do I
have to grab it do I have to grab no
okay okay I got my hand is it's too far
oh no no no no it's a big boy okay it's
such a big boy get it it's such a big
boy I'm gonna get it I'm gonna get it
I'm going for the grab hook I almost had
it that time
oh come on boo-boo take a bow take a bow
take a bow go catch it on the swing Oh
what do I do
what do we do with it how do I get off
dark no their baby boy definitely let go
of your Pole
Oh cabinet damn it mark cuttlefish I was
so close to restarting it would have
reached her I would have flown to
Cincinnati to slap you I would have
flown I would have done it my whole
chest is like free stuff oh my god
well you never to play this game again
now do we know yeah are we done with
this now yeah I think we're done yeah I
think we're done
[Music]
you